WILL FIND OUT MORE IN THE COMING
DAYS.
CONGRESSMAN >> Jason:C
CONGRESSMAN >> Jason:N
CONGRESSMAN >> Jason:R
CONGRESSMAN >> Jason:S
CONGRESSMAN >> Jason:M
CONGRESSMAN >> Jason:Y
CONGRESSMAN >> Jason:C
CONGRESSMAN >> Jason:M
CONGRESSMAN >> Jason:E
HOLD TIGHT THERE.
WE WANT TO GO TO MATT WHOSE ON
THE GROUND IN ANNAPOLIS
>> BECOMING AN S CLEANING SCENE
OUTSIDE OF MANELLA'S WE SAW
PEOPLE LIGHTING SPEED FORMAT
HATS ON FIRE, WASHINGTON POLICE
HOLDING CALLING THE PIGS, AND
RIGHT NOW, THERE'S A
CONFRONTATION OF REPORTERS WIND
UP AGAINST POLICE, IT'S KIND OF
SETTLED DOWN NOW.
FOR A WHILE, THIS IS A PRETTY
INTENSE SCENE.
HERE COMES SOMETHING THAT WAS
NOW, I DON'T KNOW SOMETHING FROM
POLICE OFFICERS, BUT WE SEE IT
ALL NIGHT LONG IT'S BEEN
INTENSIFYING, PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
INSTIGATORS, THERE HAVE BEEN A
FEW CHARACTERS WHO HAVE SOUGHT
TO DISRUPT AND OPPRESS THE MEDIA
HERE TONIGHT.
SEEMS LIKE RIGHT NOW, IS COMING
TO A POINT WHERE HOPEFULLY
THINGS WILL EVENTUALLY SETTLE
AND I WILL MONITOR AND UPDATE
YOU WITH THROUGHOUT THE NIGHTS.
>> Jason: BATS, I GOT A
QUESTION IF YOU CAN HEAR ME,
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN YOU
GOT 20,000
TRUMP SUPPORTER EXITING THE BUID
TRUMP SUPPORTER EXITING THE BUIN
TRUMP SUPPORTER EXITING THE BUIG
TRUMP SUPPORTER EXITING THE BUIW
TRUMP SUPPORTER EXITING THE BUIA
TRUMP SUPPORTER EXITING THE BUII
TRUMP SUPPORTER EXITING THE BUIG
TRUMP SUPPORTER EXITING THE BUIT
TRUMP SUPPORTER EXITING THE BUIE
TRUMP SUPPORTER EXITING THE BUIM
TRUMP SUPPORTER EXITING THE BUIG
TRUMP SUPPORTER EXITING THE BUIA
HATS?
>> WHAT THE QUESTION?
IS TO BE ON WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WHEN THE 20,000 PEOPLE
THAT ARE TRUMP SUPPORTER'S EXIT
>> I THINK IT'S ANYONE'S GUESS,
THERE'S POLICE AND RIGHT DEAR,
THERE'S POLICE CLOSE NEARBY
AROUND THE BLOCK, THERE'S
CERTAINLY A VERY LARGE POLICE
PRESENCE.
WE SEEN ALL TYPES OF VEHICLES,
AND YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO SEE IS
SOMEONE CAMERA BUT THERE ARE
SOME BAD ACTORS IN THIS CROWD
TONIGHT.
WE HAVE EXPERIENCED THEM, THEY
HAVE BEEN VULGAR, THEY HAVE BEEN
JUMPING IN FRONT OF OUR CAMERAS,
CURSING AT US, JUST TYPICAL FOR
ANY PROTEST AND I PERSONAL
COVERED TRUMP RALLY'S ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND TONIGHT, I WOULD SAY
RIGHT UP THERE WITH SOME OF THE
WORST INSTIGATORS.
SOME TYPE OF MIGHT HAVE BEEN
TEARGAS EARLIER, THERE'S
SOMETHING ELSE THAT WAS JUST
THROWN AT A POLICE OFFICER ON A
HORSE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE CALLING THE
OFFICERS PIGS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE HERE, SOME
PROTESTERS, WHO WERE EXERCISING
THEIR FREEDOM OF SPEECH AND
RIGHT TO PROTEST BUT ALSO
INSTIGATING.
>> Jason: MATT, HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE WE TALKING ABOUT IN
THE RIGHT AND TYPE OF
ATMOSPHERE?
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE OUT THERE?
>> I HATE THAT USE NUMBERS ON
AIR, BECAUSE I'M GOING TO GET
CRITICIZED FOR GETTING THE WRONG
ESTIMATE BUT I WOULD SAY, WE SEE
AT LEAST HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
RIGHT HERE RIGHT NOW.
AT LEAST ONE THOUSANDS OF
PROTESTERS, AND NOW IT MIGHT BE
A LOW ESTIMATE.
AGAIN, THE RALLIES WRAPPING UP,
IF YOU SEE ANY OF THOSE PEOPLE
IN THE ARENA ACTUALLY COMING OUT
AND GIVING COURSE TO WHAT WE
SING ON CAMERA.
>> Jason: SO WHAT YOU'RE SING
ON CAMERA IS THIS LINE TWEEN
POLICE AND DEMONSTRATORS AND
RUSHING POLICE, THEY ARE RUSHING
IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION PLEASE PROTESTERS ARE
FACING AWAY FROM THE ARENA.
I CAN TELL FROM MY VANTAGE
POINT, BUT HAS TO BE THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUPPORTER ARE
EXITING THE ARENA WITHOUT
RUNNING INTO THESE PEOPLE RIGHT
NOW.
WHEN THEY STARTED TO COME INTO
THE ARENA, THE PROTESTERS WERE
ALLOWED TO GET INTO CLOSE
PROXIMITY WITH THOSE PEOPLE OR
WHERE THEY SEPARATED INTO AREA?
>> WE HAVE BEEN OUT THERE ALL
DAY, AND SEEING WHAT TRUMP
RALLY'S, AND THE OBJECT WAS
THROWN AT THE HORSE, AND THE
HORSE, OBVIOUSLY REACTING TO
THIS.
IF TO ANSWER QUESTION, WE ARE UP
HERE ALL DAY, DOZENS OF PEOPLE
FLYING OFF, BUT THEY WERE
SEPARATED FROM THE PROTEST AND
WORKING AT THE PROTEST AS YOU'RE
SEEING RIGHT NOW IT DID NOT
ARRIVE UNTIL LATER IN THE
EVENING.
A MAJORITY OF THE PRESIDENT
SUPPORTERS LINING UP TO GET INTO
THE RALLY DID NOT FACE THESE
PROTESTERS ON THE WAY AND BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
SOME THAT ARE FACING THEM ON THE
WAY OUT.
>> Jason: WE SEEN A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WITH SIGNS AND YELLING
AND SCREAMING, CAN YOU GIVE US A
SENSE OF WHAT IS THEIR MESSAGE?
>> WE ARE HEARING SOME OF THESE
SIGNATURE CHANCE, SHUT IT DOWN,
YOU KNOW, I CAN'T CONFIRM BUT
OUR CREW AND OUR SECURITY
IDENTIFY WHAT ARE PROBABLY
MEMBERS OF ANTIFA, THEY HAVE THE
HANDKERCHIEFS COVERING THEIR
MOUTH, WE HAD TO RELOCATE
SEVERAL TIMES THROUGHOUT THE
NIGHT.
WE ARE OKAY, BUT THERE SEVERAL
TIMES THE INSTIGATORS WERE GOING
TO INTERFERE WITH OUR REPORTS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANTED TO DO.
THAT'S THEIR MESSAGE, THEY'RE
GOING TO SHUT YOU DOWN AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
WE SOMEONE MAY BE TO FIRES AND
JUST MOMENTS AGO, VERY MUCH
APPEARED TO BE MAGA ON FIRE, WE
SAW PEOPLE CURSING POLICE,
RUSHING AT THEM, AND WERE
STILL WITNESSING THAT RHINO.
UPFRONT BOTTLES AT POLICES ON
HORSES.
YOU'RE BACKING UP, THERE'S A
COUPLE MOMENTS JUST A SHORT
WHILE AGO THAT WERE VERY TENSE,
AND A MUCH MORE CALM SCENE.